pakistani authorities are struggling to
prevent the country's largest freshwater
lake from overflowing and adding to the
misery of millions affected by flooding
workers have breached a dike of lake
manchar to try to control the overflow
but that means nearby villages have been
inundated while more densely populated
areas have been spared for now
pakistan's largest freshwater lake keeps
getting bigger
fed by months of rain lake mancha in
southern pakistan is close to
overflowing
putting hundreds of thousands of people
in the area at risk
if beach occurs over here so whole seven
city
it will be down so the situation is
tough we are trying to contain it we're
fighting since last 48 hours
engineers made a difficult decision
to cut into an embankment to direct the
flood away from the most populated areas
and flood dozens of nearby villages
instead
authorities say the emergency breach has
already displaced a hundred thousand
people
but local reporting suggests the number
could be much higher
many who fled say they haven't received
any help from the government
when the water breached the lake we got
scared and left our village and
belongings
we took our children and ran and came
here
we arrived at two in the morning and
it's been three days and nobody's come
to help us
most of us are staying under the open
sky on their own and in harm's way and
no one knows for how long
living in makeshift camps on higher
ground
the displaced face a range of health
risks such as waterborne and skin
diseases say experts
the children miss their home because
there's no replacement for your home
there is no peace
there are a lot of mosquitoes here and
it's very hot
we've asked for an electric fan but
that's impossible the children's
education has been stopped too getting
food is also very difficult we can't
even cook because there's water
everywhere
the decision to divert the flood waters
has spared the larger cities near lake
mancha for now
but at great human cost elsewhere
but with more rain expected to fall this
month
pakistan's disastrous summer might not
be over yet
let's bring in andres lagari here he's
with the united nations children's fund
unicef he joins us from
porcas in pakistan's southeastern sindh
province thanks for taking time to join
us now you've been touring areas
impacted by the floods describe the
situation for us
well thank you terry uh i have been in
three districts out of the many affected
in this province right now which is the
most affected province of the country uh
i have seen
hundreds and thousands of people
thousands of people on the roadside uh
on wherever i go where whichever
township i visit it's water on both
sides of the road and it's just people
sitting on the roadside waiting for help
there is of course uh certain uh there
are certain camps that have been set up
there are camps but there are filled
there are no no more capacity in that in
those camps and more camps are still
being set up a lot of work is being done
but there is still so much more to be
done and i see hundreds and uh hundreds
and hundreds of children without food uh
without without clean water there is
this this these stagnant flat water
lakes as i've been calling them
around around the province and somewhere
they are six feet deep somewhere there
are five feet and then in cities where
you've just uh
where i just mentioned the muncher lake
this the city surrounding the muncher
lakes like keyansha and so many other
cities are entirely drowned and there is
uh there is danger looming so what we
see now is just women and children uh
who are waiting for for whatever they
can get food nutrition uh health related
uh services pregnant ladies are pregnant
women are still uh waiting for any uh
services and there are uh men and
families and communities who are in the
camps on the roadside whatever is coming
their way they're just using it
now your organization specializes in
helping children in these situations
they're among the most vulnerable are
they getting the help they need for the
most part
well the people
i mean we are the organizations whoever
are on ground they're trying their best
unicef is also trying our best we have
brought in just just by just two days
ago we brought in 32 metric tons of aid
uh through a chartered flight that is
now handed over to come and it's going
to the people we are trying more to get
more aid
and more supplies it's more about
supplies right now so that we can also
get those supplies into the hands of the
people who are most in need but uh as i
said it's just i mean the effort is is
gradually reaching as many people as it
can reach and there are so many people
out there still
still are still on the move still
stranded in the flooded areas so they're
still hard to reach so we need more help
now officials say a third of the country
has been flooded over 1300 people are
confirmed dead millions of homes
destroyed do you think pakistan will
ever be the same
it's going to be a difficult
difficult journey for this country
it's going to take years to come back to
at least even the point where we were
before this flood and even that was not
an entirely ideal point of course in
terms of the health system in terms of
so many things challenges for children
women i can speak for uh it's just that
i mean it's it's definitely not going to
be the same for this country but we this
is this is a country brazilian people uh
the volunteer effort has been great and
uh the the support that that the global
community is providing is good right now
but more is needed but yes absolutely it
is going to be a difficult time coming
for pakistan
andres legari with unicef in sin
province pakistan thank you so much
while the rain has stopped in some parts
of the country the threats posed by the
floods haven't i asked a reef jaba khan
of the charity group water aid about the
biggest risks for people in the affected
areas
well obviously the short-term needs as
was shown by your report is around
shelter and food but most importantly i
think water and sanitation and hygiene
products are
very much in demand because there is
risk of diseases in fact you know we
have seen areas where the number of
waterborne diseases malaria diarrhea has
gone up
tremendously but i think this is just
the tip of the iceberg because we are
also looking at some medium-term and
long-term issues that these people are
going to face that even once the flood
water recedes the water sanitation
systems will be contaminated and you
know people if they don't if they are
not decontaminated
if they use this then you know the risks
will be much higher but also i think
from an economic terms uh the
you know the these people are dependent
on agriculture for their livelihoods
especially the rural people and you know
in in a few weeks time the winter crop
uh cropping time will come up and if
they don't crop on time you know we are
looking at you know medium term food
security issues as well
yeah that food security definitely an
issue but if we go back to the health
care pakistan's health care system was
already overstretched and underfunded
before the floods hit are people going
to be able to get the help that they
need
yeah well you know we just come out of
the cove we have issues with polio so
yes and even whatever infrastructure we
had you know that has also been
destroyed you know i was looking at you
know some of the reports which talked
about health uh you know health centers
i mean i visited some areas where the
the local hospitals have two feet of
water in it so even the whatever
services we had that had been affected
by it as well so yes you know a chronic
issue has now been exacerbated by
this flood as well
is pakistan getting enough help from the
international community
uh no i think you know it's it's far
less than what is needed on the ground
we are now in two weeks into the the
flood situation but the resources are
just you know trickling in
uh government is trying to establish
coordination mechanisms and these are
beings at the local level as well as
provincial national level uh but this
picture we are seeing on the ground is
that yes you know the
the support from the international
community in the short term is low but
also i think you know in the recovery
and rehabilitation phase you know it
will take a long time for the country to
come out of it uh so there are those
aspects as well that in the short term
we need support but also in the medium
and long term a lot of support will be
needed by the government as well as by
the people i wanted to ask you about
that the sheer scale of this disaster
how long will it take or will will
pakistan be able to recover from this
well we did recover you know first from
2005 earthquake and then 2010 floods and
then after 2010 we had floods in 11 and
12 as well uh and even some communities
are still recovering from that it this
is going to be actually a long haul and
what you know what we would expect the
international community is not just to
look at the short-term support now in
terms of response uh and recovery but
also in in in the long run you know how
can the people and government of
pakistan be supported for example
through you know uh you know a lot of
our budgets go into debt servicing so
you know donors should be able to come
forward and at least take out the
interest or or or restructure the
uh the
the the debt that pakistan owes to those
donors and this happened in kobe so we
had precedence and i think whatever
resources that can be spread now
with the gov for the government and
people to be able to respond and and
also to be able to support in
rehabilitation will be very useful and
i'm talking about next you know five six
years it'll take at least two to come
back to some level of normalcy for us
long road ahead rf khan country director
of water aid thank you for your time
today
thank you thank you for having me